♪♪
Narrator: A DRY-ERASE BOARD
IS A NONPERMANENT SURFACE
MOST COMMONLY USED
IN PROFESSIONAL
OR CLASSROOM ENVIRONMENTS.
YOU SIMPLY WRITE ON THE BOARD
WITH A DRY-ERASE MARKER
AND USE A SPECIALIZED CLOTH
TO WIPE AWAY THE MARKINGS.
THESE EFFECTIVE TOOLS
ARE AN EASY WAY
TO GET YOUR MESSAGE ACROSS.
DRY-ERASE BOARDS ARE ALSO
KNOWN AS WHITEBOARDS.
THE BOARDS WIPE PERFECTLY CLEAN
DUE TO ITS NONPOROUS SURFACE
AND THE DRY-ERASE INK.
DRY-ERASE INK CONTAINS
RELEASE AGENTS
WHICH PREVENT THE PIGMENTS
FROM PERMANENTLY
ADHERING TO THE SURFACE.
GREEN AND BLACK DRY-ERASE BOARDS
CAN ALSO BE USED AS CHALKBOARDS,
WHILE GRAY AND LOW-GLOSS WHITE
DOUBLE AS PROJECTION BOARDS.
THE SURFACE MATERIAL IS A
PORCELAIN-COATED STEEL SHEET --
FLEXIBLE ENOUGH TO BE ROLLED UP,
BUT ALSO PRESSURE SENSITIVE.
♪♪
TO START, THE ROLL IS MOUNTED
ON A CUTTING MACHINE.
♪♪
A TECHNICIAN PROGRAMS
THE MACHINE TO CUT THE ROLL
TO A SPECIFIC LENGTH
BASED ON THE BOARD'S DIMENSIONS.
WORKERS VERIFY THE LENGTH AND
CHECK THAT THE PIECE IS SQUARE.
THE SURFACE MATERIAL
WILL BE APPLIED
TO ONE OF SEVEN TYPES
OF SUBSTRATE,
RANGING FROM CARDBOARD
TO MEDIUM-DENSITY FIBERBOARD
KNOWN AS MDF.
THE NEXT STEP IS TO CUT
THE LARGE SHEET OF SUBSTRATE --
IN THIS CASE, MDF --
INTO BOARD-SIZE PIECES.
ANOTHER TECHNICIAN
ENTERS THE LENGTH AND WIDTH
INTO THE CUTTING MACHINE.
♪♪
ONCE COMPLETE, THE MACHINE
EJECTS THE SUBSTRATE,
WHICH IS NOW CUT
TO THE EXACT SIZE OF THE BOARD.
♪♪
NEXT, THE SUBSTRATE IS PUT
THROUGH A HOT-GLUE MACHINE.
THE MACHINE APPLIES
POLYURETHANE ADHESIVE
TO WHAT WILL BE THE BACK
OF THE DRY-ERASE BOARD.
AS THE SUBSTRATE EXITS,
A SHEET OF FOIL
IS APPLIED TO THE GLUED SURFACE.
THE FOIL PREVENTS MOISTURE
FROM ENTERING,
WHICH WOULD WARP THE SUBSTRATE.
THE BOARD MOVES THROUGH
TWO STEEL ROLLERS
WHICH FLATTEN THE FOIL
AND PRESS OUT ANY TRAPPED AIR.
NEXT, THE SURFACE MATERIAL
IS APPLIED
TO THE OTHER SIDE
OF THE SUBSTRATE.
A CRAFTSWOMAN USES AN AIR HOSE
TO CLEAR AWAY ANY DUST
FROM THE SIDE OF THE BOARD.
ONCE CLEANED, THE BOARD
GOES THROUGH THE GLUE MACHINE.
THE PORCELAIN STEEL SHEET
IS PLACED ON THE GLUED SURFACE.
TECHNICIANS WORK CAREFULLY
TO ENSURE THEY DON'T TOUCH
THE PRESSURE-SENSITIVE SURFACE
WITH THEIR FINGERS.
THEN THE BOARD MOVES
THROUGH THE STEEL ROLLERS
TO PRESS THE PORCELAIN STEEL
FLAT AND REMOVE ANY TRAPPED AIR.
♪♪
ONCE 50 BOARDS ARE STACKED,
TECHNICIANS PUT THEM IN A PRESS
FOR HALF AN HOUR,
UNTIL THE GLUE CURES.
♪♪
IN ANOTHER PART OF THE FACTORY,
A MACHINE CUTS MATERIAL
TO CREATE THE BOARD'S FRAME.
IT PUNCHES "V"-SHAPED NOTCHES
IN THE LENGTH OF ALUMINUM TRIM.
THE TRIM BENDS AT EACH NOTCH
TO FORM A WRAPAROUND FRAME.
♪♪
SOME BOARDS COME WITH A MARKER
TRAY THAT RUNS ALONG THE BOTTOM.
TO MAKE THESE TRAYS,
A TECHNICIAN CUTS
BOARD-LENGTH PIECES
FROM A PIECE
OF "L"-SHAPED METAL TRIM.
♪♪
SINCE THE TRAY ENDS ARE SHARP,
A TECHNICIAN ATTACHES
PLASTIC COVERS FOR PROTECTION.
♪♪
HE SECURES THE PLASTIC
END COVERS WITH SCREWS
ON BOTH ENDS OF THE PART.
♪♪
MEANWHILE, TECHNICIANS
PEEL OFF THE PROTECTIVE FILM
COVERING THE WRITING SURFACE.
♪♪
THEN THEY FLIP OVER THE BOARD
TO ASSEMBLE THE PARTS
FROM THE BACK.
♪♪
THIS MODEL DOESN'T HAVE THE
TRADITIONAL WRAPAROUND FRAME.
INSTEAD, IT HAS A FRAME
COMPRISED OF FOUR STRAIGHT
"C"-SHAPED PIECES
THAT FIT OVER THE BOARD'S EDGES.
TO ADD STABILITY,
TECHNICIANS ATTACH SCREWS
THROUGH THE TRIM
INTO THE SUBSTRATE.
♪♪
ONCE ASSEMBLY IS COMPLETE,
THE DRY-ERASE BOARD
IS PLACED INTO A BOX,
READY TO BE SHIPPED TO A
BUSINESS OR CLASSROOM NEAR YOU.